[Musique]
dans cette ville paisible dans ces
rues calmes quelque chose de terrifiant quelque chose d'
horrifiant arrive excusez-moi
ce n'était pas un animal sauvage
c'est vraiment horrible peut-être que la pire chose
que j'aie jamais
vue c'était des animaux sauvages alors qu'est-ce que tu fais
pensant que je pense aux zombies ce que vous
savez les goules morts-vivants magnifiques oh mon dieu
êtes-vous dans cet ensemble
zombies mangeurs de chair ne plaisantez pas c'est
vraiment vraiment effrayant
oh oh mec ça ne va pas bien se terminer
ils gravitent vers les choses qu'ils ont faites
quand ils  étaient vivants appelés pipi est-ce qu'elle
vient de dire Chardonnay
ouais elle l'a fait
morts-vivants je peux voir que
excusez-moi ce sont de très bonnes
coupes vous avez joué au ballon de la ligue mineure
n'avez-vous pas bien un peu de classe il y
a longtemps
[Musique]
vous